a fighter jet screams along the border
in northern thailand at the end of june
it's happened several times this year
and children know the drill
hiding in shelters until the skies are
clear
but the jets are aiming their guns into
myanmar
although conflict on the border is
decades old the air war is new
since last year's coup the junta has
deployed attack helicopters and fighter
jets against armed rebels opposing its
rule
so our true underground like when the
jet come
uh we get a heist
uh they don't really care about
is is that a civilian place or is that a
enemy place
they just born everywhere they just
shoot the rocket
and everywhere they just shoot the
machine gun like everywhere
the attacks have been relentless and
there's little the rebels can do they're
like machine guns and small arms are no
match for the aerial bombardment
and there's one plane they fear more
than any other every uh
airplane attack
in currently they use that that blue
blue color
one yeah 130.
the yak 130 a russian two-seater jet is
sometimes described as a trainer but has
full attack capabilities
the initial fleet was ordered before the
coup
but according to a report by independent
investigators myanmar witness
another delivery has arrived since the
military took over housed in these newly
constructed hangars
using social media and geo-location the
report alleges these planes have been
deployed in civilian areas
firing unguided serbian rockets
the 80 millimeter ammunition is usually
heat which means high explosive
anti-tank when it comes to the
possibility of aiming this
ordinance precisely two targets it's not
really accurate naturally
these people were fleeing aerial and
artillery attacks on the eastern town of
lake or in december
since then more than a million people
have been displaced from their homes
across myanmar their greatest fear
attack from the skies tony chang al
jazeera